what is a secret trick that you have to
rockin all those tiny costumes because
there's a lot of a lot of pieces that
have to stay in a lot of places there it
a double sided tape is a big one and
it's like industrial-strength
double-sided tape it takes the turn off
when you when you take the costume off
it's so intense but I had that notorious
nip slip about a year ago and so I am
covered in head to toe with double sided
tape pull it up just a touch just for
the family okay did that make you a
little trepidatious me and the rest of
the show that everyone at ABC was how
cool oh my god and so now I get triple
checked every show to make sure that I
am in nice and tight and nothing's gonna
fall out anywhere what does a check
entail is it multiple people examining
you like your doctor's I mean what are
we talking here when when we're getting
dressed the Wardrobe team has lined my
costume with double-sided tape and they
put it on and then I get checked by a
female producer just to make sure that
everything is taped in and then we're
good to go
plink tsa even then I'm sure they still
have anxiety because that was really
intense when Tom had to turn around on
live television and tell me that I had
one of my nipples out of my costume gosh
but it couldn't have been more mortified
really yes I mean I had to laugh it off
because what else can you do it's
happening it's literally out there at
that point um but the funniest part is
that I just had absolutely no idea I
mean when you went home that night were
you watching the footage back like over
and over again mortified it's like I
cannot believe that happens you never
think it's gonna happen to you until it
does
you